with the epsilon designed by Momo Lancia
has an extroverted City roundabouts on
offer the little Italian is easy to
maneuver through narrow alleyways and is
now a real looker to our car testa
Montes curette took a closer look at it
fine his first impression was quite good
though he would have prefered totter
steering the steering can be made even
softer by pressing the city button but
it does make a drive through the inner
city more relaxed
the two-tone paint job gives the epsilon
a sporty elegant appearance the radiator
grille provides an optical accent the
body of the car is matte black above and
red below the Momo design is the secret
of the sporty look the rear has two
chrome-plated fake exhaust pipes and
gracefully swooping rear lights
opinion on the Epsilon's design varies
mafia montes reminds us that this is a
compact but the materials used and the
optional extras make the car feel as if
it were in a higher class of vehicle our
tester is full of praise for Momo's
designers and Lancias builders and the
Yongsan med it's financially mine no
bowels replacement that's a failure the
Epsilon's interiors well style to the
textile seats are comfortable and
good-looking the GPS device is moveable
and the instrument buttons are
ergonomically
the epsilon also has a socket for an mp3
player up on the dashboard our
instruments charmingly reminiscent of
Lancias long past days but our tester
doesn't like how the instruments are
positioned Monta says the controls here
in the middle take some getting used to
a driver is used to having information
on his speed the engine's rpms and the
like right in front of him the epsilon
and some other cars shift these gauges
to the center but he doesn't have to
like it
- nique mattes takes the car onto a
rural highway where the Epsilon performs
well despite its soft steering it's a
lot of fun to drive on curvy country
roads
the engine seems powerful and
accelerates the lancia rapidly and the
transmission is impressive too
das - hi David the gearshift lever is
located farther forward toward the
dashboard as in many transporters
because otherwise the path is so far to
the floor where the switching rod is
installed the Lancia Ypsilon shift lever
is almost on the level of the
air-conditioning montes thinks this
isn't a bad idea it's easily accessed
and the shift path is short if the
transmission felt a little less clunky
it would be perfect with its 1.3 liter
MultiJet diesel engine the epsilon
consumes only 3.9 litres of fuel per 100
kilometers its top speed is 183
kilometers an hour
the generous outfitting of the epsilon s
is reflected in the price if you want to
save money you're better off with a
gasoline model
and in summary
Namie Amuro food Monta says a premium
feel has its premium price the Lancia
Ypsilon costs at least 12,000 euros in
Germany the version he is driving today
costs almost 17,000